economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche qué bueno tenerla de vuelta acá se
esperan qué esperan las autoridades
económicas mundiales para este 2021
daniela a la raddho un extraño no claro
que sí pues mire el 2020 a cabo pero la
pandemia no lo hizo y esto sugiere que
las perspectivas siguen siendo poco
alentadoras sobre todo en medio de
segundas y terceras olas de contagios
alrededor del mundo para américa latina
la cepal espera un crecimiento conjunto
del 3,7 por ciento este año según su más
reciente informe publicado en diciembre
perú lideraría al alza con un 9 por
ciento seguido de panamá y bolivia más
abajo aparecen en república dominicana
colombia chile y argentina con cerca del
5 por ciento pero hay que hacer dos
aclaraciones raúl primero que el
comportamiento de 2020 sabemos que fue
negativo pero no se conoce todavía y
segundo que la verdadera razón para un
repunte del 2021 es que el pib anual se
compara normalmente frente al año
anterior
y de que aunque la situación pinta mejor
lo realmente difícil será volver a los
niveles de producción prepandémica así
daniela cambiamos de tema porque el
cierre de las plantas de ford en brasil
causó polémica sí señor raúl este martes
hubo protestas en el municipio de
taubaté en el estado de sao paulo los
trabajadores rechazaron el anunciado
cierre definitivo de las tres plantas de
la multinacional de automóviles ford en
el país luego de un siglo de operación
se estima que unas cinco mil personas se
van a quedar sin empleo aunque la
empresa argumenta que su decisión se
debe a la poca demanda que han tenido
por años que empeoró con la pandemia
pues eso no es lo que cree el gobierno
escuchemos
y que quiere for four no dijo la verdad
quieren subsidios ustedes quieren que
siga dándoles 20 mil millones de reales
como lo hicimos en los últimos años su
dinero sus impuestos para hacer autos
aquí no perdieron la competencia lo
siento pero yo con cogersa lo amigos
bueno angeli los reguladores de reino
unido y nueva zelanda volvieron a
advertir sobre el riesgo de las criptas
maneras raúl por estos días hay euforia
en el mercado porque el bitcoin que es
una moneda virtual de curso no legal y
sin respaldo de las autoridades ha
registrado récords uno tras otro
hoy su valor está por encima de los 30
mil dólares pero llegó a superar los 40
mil la semana pasada pues el regulador
financiero del reino unido dijo en un
comunicado que invertir en cripto
activos o inversiones y préstamos
vinculados a ellos generalmente implica
asumir riesgos muy altos con el dinero
de los inversores y agrega que si los
consumidores invierten en este tipo de
productos deben estar preparados para
perder todo su dinero así como lo oye y
en nueva zelanda pues medios locales
reportaron que hoy 6
la misma advertencia y suspendieron la
implementación de la polémica reforma
agraria mire el máximo tribunal del país
suspendió temporalmente la
implementación de esta reforma y ordenó
la creación de un comité de expertos
para negociar con los agricultores esto
después de casi dos meses de protestas y
bloqueos de carreteras y expliquemos un
poco ron mire las leyes fueron aprobadas
en septiembre y el descontento radica en
que cada año el gobierno de narendra
modi ejecuta el programa de compras de
alimentos más caro del mundo lo hace en
arroz y trigo en las regiones de punjab
y de jair jana y establece para eso un
precio mínimo de compra eso es lo que
quieren hacer ahora es permitir que las
grandes empresas negocian directamente
con los campesinos pero ellos saben que
los vayan a presionar para bajar sus
precios
daniela indicadores como cerrar a los
mercados hoy martes mira wall street de
cerró con leves ganancias a la que no le
fue muy bien fue a twitter que perdió un
2 37% por segunda jornada después del
desplome del 6 por ciento del lunes eso
tras suspender la cuenta del president
donald trump a las plazas europeas
también tuvieron un día plano aunque más
inclinado hacia el descenso y en américa
latina hubo cierres mixtos con alzas en
argentina y en brasil cifra el día para
terminar un millón de sandalias por
valor de 17 millones de dólares
raúl esto importó perú en solo diciembre
casi cuatro veces más en volumen que una
que un año atrás y esto tiene nombre
propio y es 'el hobbit' un informe de la
cámara de comercio de lima dice que el
repunte se debe al aumento del
teletrabajo pues las personas quieren
estar más cómodas en sus casas al menos
mientras dure la pandemia así genera
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información económica ustedes también
gracias continué con nosotros y muy
buena noche
[Música]